john kerry ran on 2 trillion dollars
over 10 years barack obama ran on 1
trillion hillary 2 trillion joe biden
ran on 11 trillion
it's all but inevitable that donald
trump who signed off on a record-busting
federal budget of 6.6 trillion dollars
will be replaced in the white house by
joe biden
who's promising more new spending than
any other president in history
to fund a platform that the washington
post called
more liberal than that of every past
democratic nominee
oh this is the bolsheviks versus the
mensheviks yeah i mean yes the menshviks
are the moderates but i mean we're all
so far to the left right now it used to
be a trillion dollar policy
would shock people and now a
trillion-dollar policy gets laughed at
for being insufficient
brian riedel is a budget analyst at the
manhattan institute who closely watches
how much the federal government spends
and how much it adds to the national
debt the deficit's not going to come
back below a trillion dollars again i
don't believe
large and growing federal spending
reduces long-term economic growth and
crowds out private investment
but riedel says another major problem is
that the increases will
simply soak up too much of government
spending let's just look at the interest
cost
right now interest rates are low but if
interest rates spike
the interest cost could absolutely
destroy the federal budget
for every point interest rates rise it
costs about one and a half or two
trillion dollars over the decade
over the next 30 years even if interest
rates stay
low the principal gets so big so then
at a certain point the bond market gets
nervous they see the debt rising that
much
and they start to demand higher interest
rates cbo
says that by 2050
the gdp will be six thousand dollars
lower per capita
than if we stabilize the national debt
six thousand dollars per capita
just from the economy growing more
slowly because
the savings are going to the government
for spending rather than businesses for
investment
riedl doesn't see biden rising to the
challenge of reigning in spending
especially on old age entitlements such
as medicare and social security
that are ultimately driving automatic
budget increases
there's one of two paths to fixing this
number one you need a ross perot kind of
person who comes and gets everybody
motivated about it
i don't see that on the horizon right
now because democrats don't want to
touch these programs and republicans
increasingly don't want to touch these
programs because their working class
base is more dependent on them if that's
the case
you need the economy to force action if
the economy starts to get
sluggish interest rates start to rise
the bond market gets nervous
that's what can force action the problem
is by that point
you're already kind of beginning a
fiscal crisis
and you have a lot less wiggle room and
you have to be a lot more drastic
which is why i would love for there to
be somebody who can motivate people to
take this seriously now
but you know you know how things go in
democracies you usually wait until
there's a crisis
and then and then do something drastic
ridle says that one piece of good news
from the 2020 election
is that biden will have trouble enacting
much of his budget busting agenda
i am more optimistic than i was when i
thought the democrats were gonna run the
table
with a split government you're not gonna
see that much
change from the baseline i think in the
short term you're gonna get more
pandemic aid more recession aid not
nearly the three trillion dollars the
democrats want
but maybe another trillion dollars over
the next year or so
from there president trump is campaigned
on two trillion dollars in
infrastructure
joe biden campaigned on two trillion
dollars in infrastructure
there might be a bipartisan
infrastructure deal at some point
the next four years under split
government may be a pretty quiet four
years from a policy level
but hitting the snooze bar on new
spending won't save us from the fiscal
nightmare that lies ahead
the overton window has shifted so far
bernie sanders ran on 97 trillion over
10 years
elizabeth warren ran on 45 trillion over
10 years
and so all of a sudden biden's a
moderate
you